and ponder the question
what if
i see marvel has learned nothing from
their titling mistakes in captain
america civil war there was an idea
to bring together a group of remarkable
people i know i've heard the speech if
your characters are getting tired of the
recaps and references imagine how your
audience must feel about them also
finishing someone else's sentence people
need to quit thinking that it's cute
because it's not it's just [ __ ]
annoying for the initial person talking
and anyone listening to the conversation
letting your signature iron man scene be
an homage to iron man 2. and i know
that's the time frame of when all this
is taking place but what if there was no
iron man 2. did i ever tell you about
this one time i actually recruited a
russian assassin to join my american
covert ops team sounds like an
interesting story certainly an idea
worth exploring perhaps in a movie
marvel should get right on that 10 years
ago then you should know i'm not afraid
of a big swing i wish this show wasn't
afraid of a big swing then we might get
some story lines a little more
interesting than what if this character
was replaced by this character sir i'm
going to have to ask you to exit the
donut is stark truly inside the donut
though i mean is the hole in a ring
donut truly a part of its whole or is it
simply the acknowledgement of an absence
of donut was it ever truly whole to
start with is it more or less whole with
or without a toll damn it marvel give us
the answers we truly crave
god what'd she just do to me i'm pretty
sure romanov just poked you without your
explicit consent since you're about to
die horrible death stark we'll take care
of the sitting don't you worry i'm the
watcher hold on are we getting treated
to two narrated exposition dumps in the
first five minutes jeffrey right on this
wasn't me i know that but shield has
protocols so my hands like yours are
tied actually i don't understand this at
all romanov will take the syringe to dr
ross and find out that the serum was
never even injected in the stark this
should have been easily detected by
shield csi or whatever they have and
should have resulted in further
investigation into the matter they are
charging roman off with a crime and
wiping their hands way too quickly glad
real life authorities never do that
right
right here mind holding these for me of
course huh
what even though the guard is only
fooled by this for 1 19 of a second he
is still fooled by it for precisely 1
19th of a second too long i never did
get what he sees in her sure she can
land a punch but only cause people don't
expect it that's black widowest it's
always fun to watch black widow kick
some ass but once again we have an
action set piece with a large group of
guards attacking the protagonist one
maximum two at a time instead of
immediately overwhelming them with sheer
superior numbers
[Music]
well that doesn't sound ominous at all
it's been happening all night the
artifact has a bit of an attitude or
maybe it's just a storm also no one can
lift it not even jackson and he does
crossfit do you mean chris crossfit
jackson do you know he's also vegan and
that he doesn't own a television great
guy super humble he's a caucasian male
mid-20s with
really great hair
excuse me it's an accurate description
no it isn't yes chris hemsworth is about
as close to being objectively beautiful
as his humanly or as guardianly possible
but fury is right to be outraged here
great hair is not a remotely helpful or
appropriate descriptor he's making a
move on the hammer one shot one kill sir
to say the word why go for a kill shot
at all wasn't the idea to find out more
about the hammer from whoever came to
retrieve it i swear i didn't shoot
your arrow would indicate otherwise nick
fury would be excellent at tv sins this
doesn't make any sense
i don't slip i don't miss fire vanity
what's the word on our intruder did from
an arrow how did a damn arrow kill thor
he's a god the man was hit with a
[ __ ] neutron star for crying out loud
an arrow [ __ ] off with your nonsense
even while rotting he smells like
lavender really
this sudden obsession with thor's beauty
and appealing olfactory presence is
understandable but slightly creepy i
don't remember anyone sniffing him the
first time around maybe that's the real
sin here dr ross not sure if you
remember me but i used to sound like
scarlett johansson and now i sound like
lake bell doing an impersonation of
scarlett johansson well your injector's
clean
and there's no traces of lethal
pathogens of any kind what the college
medical clinic resident told me after my
sdd test somehow makes its way into this
episode
what was the point of asking her if she
was in a secure location if you're just
going to go ahead with the damn news
anyway also if you're going to inform
someone that their friend and colleague
has just been murdered maybe don't
preface it with a quippy i've got bad
news and worst news
go get em boss professional sideline
cheerleaders you would do best to kneel
before a god we don't really do that
here no matter who or what you are
unless you're the queen of england but
other than that no one well other than
the person you're proposing marriage to
but other than those two people no one
well some people like to kneel in front
of important stature you know what fury
we actually kneel quite a bit
i am loki crown prince of asgard the
rightful king of yerton
this ring's on for some time and i have
no idea why i know it's played for
comedy but in reality there's no reason
to allow phone to continue to ring over
a clearly important conversation if the
intent is to pick up the call then pick
it up and excuse yourself damn it if you
have no intention of picking it up then
decline the call takes a special kind of
[ __ ] to allow a phone to persistently
ring in this hugely distracting manner
excuse me for just a second hello a
multiverse of infinite diversity and
innumerable outcomes yet in this
timeline banner still ends up in the
exact same glass corridor at the exact
same time colonel ross and his friends
turn up what's in the box
such insolence will not be tolerated
insolence does what's in the box have an
unfortunate translation in asgardian i
mean unless you're talk oh
but he can't die
he can't die
he can't he can we are not allies then
let me help you um fury he just said you
weren't allies in case you confused it
with manasseh wait is this the only
manassas in the whole world then i guess
there truly is no good reason to include
the state in this subtitle i'm not
telling you my password
why not
steve steve steve i heart steve oh 704
this is a perfectly fine password to use
for personal accounts and such but it's
absolutely ludicrous that coulson would
use it for work as well yes in theory it
should only ever be known by him but i
also know that chael's entire it
department would never be able to look
colson in the eye wow good one colson
what does coulson mean what his
reluctance to share his password was at
least partly because it was embarrassing
as all hell so why the surprise at black
widow's understandable reaction for some
inexplicable reason our mystery
assailant who has been doing a fantastic
job of covertly taking out earth's
mightiest heroes and hawkeye decides to
switch to this very noisy and aggressive
beatdown for black widow do they know
the third act resolution is coming
because they really shouldn't furious
it's all about hope i can't think of a
single reason why black widow would
choose to communicate this vital
breakthrough in a way that is so vague
and open to interpretation she could
have just as easily said hope van dyne
and that would have been plenty enough
for fury to go on with no chance of it
coming off as a vague platitude but
heaven forbid were robbed of one last
twist for the sake of believable
decision making if it isn't hank pym
hank has killed everyone else with a
surprise attack but for fury he walks up
behind him as a normal-sized human so he
can talk about his motive that makes
sense you took everything from me i
wanted you to hurt wrath in this montage
of murder you can see that hank pym was
the projectile that hit bruce back at
the university but at the time we were
shown a scope moving around and taking
aim at banner mistakenly leading us to
believe it was one of ross's happy
soldiers but if this was pym all along
who shot the gun good evening my loyal
subjects so with earth's mightiest
heroes and hawkeye out of the way loki
is free to rule humanity with little
resistance but why earth with thor out
of the way couldn't he have taken over
asgard wasn't that always the plan i
believe that in this universe as in
every other hope never dies except in
this universe she definitely did oh
we're back to being metaphorical see
easy mistake
i am a god you dull creature
and i will not be bullied by that
puny god
i am the watcher
i'm gonna shoot some pictures
and
you're going to process them
there was an idea
to bring together a group of this guy
single-handedly ruined the word
[ __ ] you know how hard that is
to do
then you should know i'm not afraid of a
big swing meryl
swing away
so you like doughnuts say
you know what they call a
quarter pounder with cheese
they don't call it a quarter pounder
with cheese they call it the royale
which
before we get started
does anyone want to get out
oh gill's in a lot of trouble
wow
even while rotting he smells like
lavender and your father smelt of
elderberries which is why i have to ask
what's in the box what's in the box
black look
michael
my god
extreme
you never cared about hope hey i didn't
even know that [ __ ]